[موسيقى]
السنه اللي فاتت اجى المطر بدر شوي وكان
المحصول اجود واكثر
واطول حته في الطول كمان اطول من السنه
هذه فتاخير تاخير المطر اثر على المحصول
اشي طبيعي حياثر على المحصول على كميه
الانتاج كمان اشي طبيعي يعني والحمد لله
بقى ابتدي القطعه طلعت
ربع طن وقله الامطار
[تصفيق]
هذه بقت السبله طويله طويله بتكون طويله
والحبه ناصحه
ضعيفه يعني ضعيفه جدا والمحصول يعني مش زي
كل سنه
[موسيقى]
الارض الموجوده في قطاع غزه بتزيدش بتخس
لانه بزرعوا فيها اشجار زيتون حاجه محتاج
خضره فكل سنه عن سنه وبنيان جديد بتتخلص
هذه الاراضي وتنزل من مساحتها فهذه بادي
الى ازمه ثانيه في المحاصيل القمح عنا
وقله القمح عنا
محصول القمح المساحه المزروعه حوالي
10,000 دونم طبعا انتاجها حوالي 4000 طن
هذه الكميات المنتجه لا تكفي من الاكتفاء
من حاجتنا حوالي باب فقط اثنين في الميه
ويتم الاستعاضه بالكميات اللي بنحتاجها
الى الاستيراد من الخارج تصل نسبه
الاستيراد الى 98% طبعا محصول القمح من
المحاصيل التي لا يمكن عمليه الاكتفاء في
الوصول الاكتفاء الذاتي بسبب محدوديه
الاراضي في قطاع غزه
[تصفيق]
تغير المناخي هو احد
الظواهر الان تمثل بشكل كبير خطوره على
القطاع الزراعي بخصوصا الامطار
والمحاصيل البعليه اللي بتعتمد بشكل كبير
على الامطار زي القمح مثلا حيث انه عدم
انتظام كميات الامطار وسقوطها وعدم توزيع
عادل للايام الماطره اثر بشكل كبير على
كميات الانتاج اللي تاثر السواء في جوده
المنتج او في كميه الانتاج بحيث انه قل
انتاج عن العام الماضي بالنسبه لمحصول
القمح